if you invite a man out on a date
maybe grab a drink
grab some lunch, dinner
he should not have to pay the entire tab
now before you get angry
put yourself in his shoes.
if he asks you out on a date
would you expect him to leave you with an entire tab
no, no you wouldn't
so why are you inviting him out expecting him to pay the entire Bill
if you ask someone out
you generally pay the Bill
YOU are asking them out
or you could split it
but generally if you're asking someone out
you're inviting them out to treat them
This really shouldn't be a debate
it's common decency
And for the love of god and anything sacred
stop expecting a relationship to work if it's only one sided